der fonds mit dem video losgeht leute
erst mal ein herzliches gut kick in die
runde
klein ich möchte ab sofort die animation
ein bisschen anders gestalten als in den
folgender vor und für die zeichnung dann
möchte ich dann immer auftritt live
gehen das heißt vielleicht habt ihr es
schon mitbekommen
vielleicht habt ihr jetzt diese folge
quasi schon ein bisschen gespoilert
willkommen auftritt wenn nicht dann
folgt mir hier auf diesem trip kanal und
dann verpasst du auch keine folge kein
streaming ihr könnt mir natürlich auch
instagram und twitter folgen
da werde ich natürlich auch bescheid
geben wenn ich live gehe und ja ich
möchte einfach dass man mit dem stream
ausprobieren und hoffe dass das auch so
klappt wie sie mir vorstelle
[Gelächter]
und jetzt geht es los mit der folge und
weil man geschrieben hat dass meine
begrüßung total kindisch ist habe ich es
wieder mal waren und bekam zu einer
neuen folge
drobny seit der letzten folge trauma dar
wie ist viel passiert ich habe viele
neue abonnenten bekommen und ich bin
schon zum zweiten mal wieder umgezogen
war ja zum zweiten mal für alle die
dieses format nicht kennen ich lese aus
meinem tagebuch vor und zwar habe ich
aus diesem tagebuch vorgelegt
zusammengefasst ich habe mich halt
ständig verliebt und wieder entliebt das
tagebuch ging von 511 2014 bis zum 17 12
2015 ein jahr
womit hat es geendet robin das ist zwar
in robin verliebt mit diesem tagebuch
sind wir aber durch und jetzt müssen wir
ein neues anfangen dazu habt ihr auch
eine story
das haben viele burschen auch niemand
bekommen ein zweites tagebuch hat man
verrückt nachbar geklaut obwohl ich
glaube es war auch nicht mein nachbar
es war glaube ich einer der immer in
unser haus rein gekommen ist und oben
ganz oben geschlafen habe ich habe auf
dem vierten gewohnt und auf dem fünften
wagen keine wohnungen aber da ging noch
eine treppe hoch ich glaube zum dach da
hatte ich also eine kiste um ein buch
drin war und dann war es im müll so war
die geschichte stimmt an falls dieses
vermisst habe mein lama ist da weil
viele von euch haben jetzt auch den shop
und so gefunden
das lama habe und es gibt auch so die
laden- und mittlerweile kannst du auch
mal wann et lama bei google eingeben und
dann kommt einfach dieses bild der shop
sollte mir was dafür geben ja machen wir
weiter mit tagebuch nummer 2 habe ich
daraus schon vorgelesen ich bin mir
nicht so sicher
ich gucke jetzt einmal kommt noch mal
wann 39 folgen es ist geschehen ich habe
verdammt noch mal mein tagebuch wieder
die story dahinter ist einfach so
unglaubwürdig ach so ich hatte das buch
fallhöhe
eines tages habe ich dem papier müll
runtergebracht und in der papiertonne
todestage behoben drauf kann ich mal
ganz kurz erwähnt wie unglaublich
schlanke ich in diesem video aussehe
ich habe auch einen riesigen kopf das
liegt aber einer kameraperspektive
ja das ist knapp zwei jahren in den zwei
jahren viel passiert
[Musik]
ok amberg geht's weiter gemacht hat
machen die denn die sind so
selbstständig das tagebuch ich von
meiner besten freundin ann christin
bekommen weil wir das nicht brauchte ja
nie
das dafür dass euch gedanke wir haben
den 24
2006 liebes tagebuch und gesagt bekommen
dass sie früher leute das schon echt
zwei jahre her mit dem westen doch ich
hoffe ihr seid mir nicht böse
das ist jetzt das erste mal dass ich bei
dir ein schreibe heute ist freitag und
ich glaube dass ich noch bei angriffs
schlafen werde
es ist bis jetzt nichts besonderes
passiert außer dass wir einen
vokabeltest geschrieben haben und sophie
hat wieder stress mit irgendeinem mädel
okay sophie war ich sag mal so heute
würde ich sagen so fiebern problemen
können das lag aber auch an ihrer mama
muss man auch ehrlich sagen dass die hat
sie ihr nicht leicht gemacht die war
einfach ein problemkind alina ist
gestern ausgezogen jetzt habe ich zwei
zimmer für mich es ist aber trotzdem
komisch so ohne an li na weil sie ja
dafür gesorgt hat dass ich keine chance
mehr bauen
wie sage ich das jetzt am besten also
sophie ist ja ein problemkind von sophie
hat dafür gesorgt dass sammer so dass
ich so ein paar sachen gemacht habe die
nicht so ganz in ordnung waren beispiele
hinter der mülltonne geraucht mit elf
oder zwölf ja- und meine schwester wenn
man so dafür gesorgt indem sie halte
dich asozial waren meinen achten gelesen
hat oder so dass ich halt merke was ich
da tue
ach ja du kennst ja gar nicht nur
vergangenheit war ich noch 2006 12 13
also eine letzten zeit drehte sich alles
um robin
und ich weiß nicht ob ich ihn noch liebe
deine vanessa wann ich dachte mit dem
neuen tagen werde ich irgendwie so ein
selbst erweitern das selbst arbeitet
eine phase da so durch macht aber nein
ich muss euch sagen robin waren der
schulband und robin war glaube ich zwei
klassen über uns und ratet mal werden
die schulband eingetreten ist nun bei
robbens zu sein
und ratet mal wer dann bei uns gab es
immer so ein weihnachtsbasar bei euch
gibt's den wahrscheinlich auch das ist
so ein typisches ding für deutsche
schulen weihnachtsfest zu machen er ist
super lustig macht spaß ich glaube ich
aber auch in einer folge mal geschrieben
dass ich mit andré und machen und
sokieba gespielt weihnachtsbaum sorgen
aber es gab einen weihnachtsbasar
bereich in der schulband muss
wahrscheinlich zu der zeit gewesen sein
will robin und ich weiß nicht warum
unsere musiklehrerin damals es findet
gute idee gehalten hat mich singen zu
lassen aber es endete damit dass ich
zwei wochen lang welt be von den beatles
üben musste weil ich das vor der schule
singen musste und ich weiß nicht wie
mein musikalisches talent kennt ich habe
halt kainz und damals auch schon nicht
ich gebe euch eine kleine gesangsprobe
ende gar america to me speaking world
with it be ann christin hat mich noch so
lange damit aufgezogen
es war es so unglaublich peinlich zum
glück hatte man damals noch keine handys
weil sonst wird es jetzt ein video von
mädchen dass dinge lesen wir doch gleich
mal noch einen tag hier und zwanzigster
dritter 27 dritter 2006 war ich wieder
aktiv liebes tagebuch ich fühle mich
nicht besonders gut weil ich nicht mit
annina zum dohmen darf und ich darf
nicht mal mich mit ihr treffen
ich erinner mich meine schwester hatte
damals einen riesigen streit mit meinen
eltern das ist so weit gegangen dass ich
auch erstmal mich mich mit ihr treffen
durfte weil ich 13 oder 12 war das war's
von meinen eltern dieser trick so nein
wir im streit mit ihr
das heißt wir können ihr jetzt noch
einen richtig rein wirken und dass somit
euch dann noch ein bisschen was das ist
so erziehung nämlich dass ich glaube ich
bin noch in robin verliebt aber ich weiß
es nicht genau
ich weiß ja auch gar nicht ob er mich
mag ich werde es ja bei der schulband
sehen
ich verstehe nicht was mit den leuten in
meiner klasse los weil die in einem
moment mit jemandem zusammen sind und im
anderen mit jemanden anderen liebes
tagebuch ich weiß nicht was mit meiner
klassenkameraden los ist kann ich ja gar
nicht nachvollziehen meint es wäre cool
mit robin zusammen zu sein
ich würde ja auch nicht sofort schluss
machen aber ich glaube weil ich erst in
der sechsten will er mich nicht
ja ich glaub eher waren beachten oder so
da vielleicht sogar schon in der neunten
seit sophie da war
reden wir sowieso nicht mehr so viel
früher war es viel besser
naja kann man mich nichts machen okay
ich mache dann mal schluss und ich
schreibe dann mal wieder rein ja ich
kann mich erinnern ich habe mich halt
angemeldet in der schulband bei robin
halt drin war und dann haben wir am
anfang viel geredet und er war so nett
zu mir
dann habe ich mich natürlich hals über
kopf in ihn verliebt und dann wollte
sophie auch mitmachen ja dann hatte
robin wahrscheinlich auch kein bock
mitzureden wenn ich dann die ganz so
viel gesessen hat und wer wollte
wahrscheinlich nur einfach nett zu mir
sein damit ich mich nicht schlecht fühle
in meinen ersten stunde in der schulband
und dann hat er halt mit mir geredet und
dann also wieder war nicht mehr und ich
habe natürlich so viele die schuld
gegeben und um die geschichte mit robin
genauso spannend zu halten wie die mit
marvin werde ich jetzt schluss machen
nicht mit robin dass es wahrscheinlich
noch eine längere nummer aber wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten mal ich
verspreche euch dass die nächste folge
viel schneller kommt als die hier und
ich habe euch die folge gefallen und ich
wünsche euch einen wunderschönen tag und
vergesst nicht am 29 märz kommt mein
buch raus das könnt ihr bestellen im
link da unten wie schmeckt's kochbuch
falls die lust habt bis zum 1
[Musik]